-Welcome back to the show,
everybody.
It is time to play a game that
combines pumpkins and painting.
It's time for
the Pumpkin Paint Challenge.
-♪ Pumpkin ♪
♪ Paint ♪
♪ Challenge ♪
-Now, this is, of course,
the game
where two audience members
compete to paint a pumpkin.
Let's see who's playing tonight.
Come on over.
Hello. Nice to see you.
-Roy Fuentes.
-What is your name,
and where are you from?
-Roy Fuentes, Baytown, Texas.
-Hey, welcome.
Thanks for being here.
Texas. I love it.
Hey.
-Hello.
-How you doing?
What's your name,
and where are you from?
-My name's Diana, and I'm
from Burlington, New Jersey.
-Hey! Come on.
A local advantage there.
Now, here's how this works.
You each have a pumpkin
and some paint,
and whoever can paint
their pumpkin better
will be declared champion
and go home
with a very special prize.
And the thing that you will be
painting is me, my face.
So why don't you head on over
there to the sides over here.
You have all the paint
I think you need.
Grab your paint.
We're gonna put one minute
on the clock.
So it's kind of a fast thing.
And you're painting my face.
I'm like a live model for you.
Ready? Set.
Why did you grab a bigger brush?
So rude. Very rude.
Rude off the bat.
Alright, but who knows?
Ready, set. Go!
This is great.
Here we go.
One minute.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Can't see what they're doing.
This is fantastic.
Alright.
We're down to 50 seconds here.
Very, very interesting.
[ Cheers and applause ]
You're already getting
some applause.
Some people can see.
Are you an artist at all?
No. You're not. Are you?
Are you an artist?
-Nope.
-No.
Neither one of you have any --
Any background in painting or --
No.
-No, sir. No, sir.
My wife's a teacher,
kindergarten teacher.
She should have been up here
instead of me.
-Oh, yeah. Okay, good. Alright.
So that's interesting.
And no background in art at all
or any of that stuff?
-No.
-Are you crafty at all?
-Like, I do musical stuff
but not anything like this.
-Oh, okay.
Are you --
Do you have a --
Do you have a Halloween costume
you're going to wear this year?
-Oh, yeah.
Commando, maybe, kilt.
-Okay. Yeah. Okay.
We have six seconds left.
Five seconds left.
Okay.
Three, two, one.
Time's up.
Paint brushes down.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Now let's see how you did.
Contestant number two,
we're going to start with you.
Here we go.
[ Drum roll ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
I like him.
I think he's --
I think he's cute.
I like this guy.
Alright.
You did a great job.
Contestant number one,
good to see you.
Let's see how you did here.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Wow.
And this is --
You're actually very talented.
This is going to be
a tough call here.
Audience, what do you think?
Is it this one?
[ Cheers and applause ]
Or is it this one.
I think it's you.
Congratulations.
You're the winner.
You're the Pumpkin Paint
champion,
and as winner,
you'll be going home with $100
and a signed pumpkin
spice latte by me, but...
they spelled my name wrong
at the top/
They put Jeremy Fallon,
so that's good.
But there you go.
Thank you very much.
Congratulations.
Thank you for playing.
Stick around.
We'll be right back with more
"Tonight Show," everybody.